Chris thank you found this big news also
a local water conservation meeting gets
heated tonight as dozens push back
against a bill proposed in the
legislature it is
the 220 and it would require some with
septic tanks to switch to the sewer
system Sasha Loftus was there tonight
shares more from both sides
Denise and Brian those we spoke with
here tonight say they're all four water
conservation but they don't believe this
is the way to do it now those backing
the bill say it's important to save
every drop here locally as possible
tensions boil over during a meeting on
water use people are upset people are
upset the event held at the Las Vegas
Valley Water District Wednesday focused
on assembly Bill 220 and its potential
impact on septic systems the problem is
they are seeding a bunch of power to a
water board that I have no control over
the proposal would give the Southern
Nevada Water Authority the power to
require those with septic tanks to
switch to the valley sewer system by
2054. every gallon returned through the
Wastewater system is another gallon we
can use those behind it call ab220 a
crucial move to meet conservation
demands as Lake Mead declines and
drought conditions continue every single
gallon that is taken out of Colorado
River and delivered to a home with
septic it goes into the ground but we
can't take that back Grant funded
Assistance programs would pay up to 85
percent of the connection costs but a
lot of property owners say it's still
too expensive some people are elderly
they're on a fixed income they just
simply can't afford it adding that their
efforts to fight back won't stop until
more changes are made don't think you're
just gonna make this uh make us go away
that's not what's going to happen
now ab-220 was approved by a committee
boat on April 10th up at the legislature
it is now set to go to the assembly
floor now important to note this does
not apply to well owners who have septic
systems now snwa says if it passes about
200 properties would be required to
convert each year reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now